so the stunt coordinator was going to
fire the air arm so it had a lead with
the button going to him off set
when he does fire the button i'm
virtually in line with the ground
so he fires the air ram which fires me
straight onto the back of my neck
and literally i'm lying on the floor and
i can't feel my legs
and this went on for about two minutes
it's the worst feeling in the world you
know i thought it was paralysed i just
could not film my legs at all
sort of broken my neck
[Music]
i think i've been very fortunate to work
on some of the biggest franchise
from double 07 bond jason bourne mission
impossible
batman obviously star wars and when we
were doing the phantom menace
i was originally called in as a fighter
ranger to choreograph all the fights
which was my primary job
but when we started to look for a double
for the ob1 character
we were searching through the stunt
register and the only people we could
or were considered to be able to do the
diversity of the job weren't available
you know because it did involve a lot of
acrobatics obviously the fighting there
was a lot of fighting a lot of weapon
work with the lightsaber fighting
there was a lot of acrobatics a lot of
wire work there was trampoline work
there was air rams
which are nitrogen systems that fire you
up in the air so
in a nutshell it came everybody looked
at me and said well why don't you do it
and then when we got in obviously it was
a lot of rehearsals a lot of prep we had
to do a test fight for george lucas
we went through a fight routine and um
yeah he loved it so i subsequently got
the part from there
can you talk about the injury you almost
sustained on star wars
there's a bit where obi-wan clashes
lightsabers with darth maul
sort of backed up against the wall i
remember ray takes his hand off for the
single dartmouth takes his hand off and
uses the force
to blast obi-wan backwards so we're
going to use an air ram for this
which is um a nitrogen system like a
like a car foot pump
a huge version of a car put pump that
fires you through the air so the stunt
coordinator was going to fire the air
arm so it had a lead with the button
going to him off set
three two one lean backwards okay and he
hasn't fired the button and i'm
continuing going backwards when he does
fire the button
i'm virtually in line with the ground so
he fires the air ram which fires me
straight onto the back of my neck
a lot of pressure a lot of psi was in
this air am
and literally i'm lying on the floor and
i can't feel my legs
and this went on for about two minutes
it's the worst feeling in the world you
know i thought it was paralyzed
could not form my legs at all sort of
broken my neck so the horror of it all
the medics are coming over and
everything else
you know no one knows what to do it's
one of those scenarios that you know you
don't want to come across
everybody's worrying i knew i was going
to hit the ground hard
because i was landing on the floor and
sliding so i used two back pads i had
two motorcycle pads one on top of the
other
and i think because they're the heavy
duty motorbike ones they went right up
to the top of my neck and i think if i
didn't have those pads on my neck would
have snapped without a doubt
and i hear obviously coming from sort of
behind the camera it's like come on in
let's go gotta do another take let's get
it done
i've worked with some very very good
physical actors that are very physical
and very up for doing everything
um tom cruise is a prime example very
physical guy a very capable guy
i think the difference between an actor
and a professional stunt performer is
everything that some performer does he
will rehearse he will test he will do an
actor will have everything tested
so they can see everything done and then
they will step into it when i'm teaching
a fight sequence to an actor
he will learn a series of moves then he
will learn the dance which is the
routine
then it's perfecting the dance and
perfecting the dance is the hard bit
that's taking you from learning a
routine
to becoming looking highly proficient
when i had the gladiator
whacking phoenix and russell crowe both
of them hadn't picked a sword up before
and my job was to train them i'd be
russell's side of the fight against
whack him all the time and i would be
reckons part of the fight against
russell all the time
we didn't actually get them together
until four days before we were shooting
the last fight which is the
emperor against maximus fight so four
days before that they had never fought
together
and it was quite funny i remember
getting us to our training area
first time they come together got
russell that side and whack him that
side and they stand there i go okay guys
take it really really slowly walk it
through slow motion and get used to each
other whack him attacks does the first
couple of moves and suddenly stops and
goes oh no
no no andreas played a little bit higher
there i'm like guys guys
you're not fighting me get used to each
other it's about you two now
i'll introduce you to freddie freddie's
been with me a long time
freddie is my fire mask when we do a
full burn this is what we wear he's made
out of a special latex
which is fire retardant he's got lenses
glass lenses
so obviously no flame can get to your
eye you've got a little hole where your
mouth is the nose is sealed you want to
hold your breath
for the run of the of the burn as long
as you can and when your adrenaline's
going
um something like 40 seconds seems like
10 minutes
i did a fire job on a big film myself
and a colleague are both standing in a
position
where liquid fire is dropped on top of
us that's the effect
we've rehearsed it all uh gone through
it all by numbers what i was going to do
how i was going to move what i was going
to bump into blah blah blah
when we stood there the liquid fire that
came down was so heavy it was like being
hit on the head with a sledgehammer so
it knocked myself my colleague
over now the room was quite confined and
there was a lot more stuff
in those tanks than we were led to
believe because when the fire hit us
it literally rolled up the walls and it
was quite a confined area
now when you're in the moment doing
whatever you're doing i remember falling
over i remember getting up remember
doing my bit now i'd finish my bit and i
was starting to feel
the the heat starting to come through
and nobody was putting me out
and i remember and i'm lying to the side
and i'm lying down
right done my bit can you please put me
out now and nobody put me out
and this you've got to not panic it's
quite a mad situation where you've got
to think this don't panic let's be
professional
something's happening they're going to
come they're going to come all i can see
is walls of orange
remember imagine the whole room is on
fire so i could just see walls of orange
i can't make out anything
and then i then i heard sort of mayhem a
lot of voices shouting and screaming
and i managed to hear the words andreas
get up and dress get up move
move so i immediately stood up the guy
putting me out
now he bumped into me and i remember his
arm got caught on fire he's all in a
fire protective suit but i remember his
arm got put on fire
then there's a fireman behind him so the
fireman's putting him out he's putting
me out
to cut a long story short for that it
was like there was too much
uh liquid fire above us in too much of a
confined area
and i actually burnt the back of my leg
and actually i ended up having to take a
slight breath so i burnt the inside of
my mouth
luckily not too bad and when things go
wrong
they can drastically go wrong very fast
i was doing a movie called judge dredd
with stallone
and i'm about 40 for up uh and i come
out of this
come out of the window get thrown out
the window by two characters playing two
thugs
special effects will put debts on the
glass okay an electric debt
like little charges on the corners of
the glass on an electric
line and they will basically fire it and
it cracks the glass
which splits the glass which allows me
to punch through it if they don't do
that i'm hitting a solid piece of
glass and it is very very heavy on you
anyway three two one action
pelted towards the glass good energy
good speed hit the glass
and it was like being hit in the face
with a sledgehammer the debts hadn't
gone off
i punched through the glass but it
nearly knocked me out went into like a
header position which is like a dive
where my body goes over so i can land on
the on my
back onto the box rig i kept my eyes
shut and i remember opening my eyes
and looking up and my legs were hanging
over the last box of the box rig and two
of my colleagues were there
if the debt could have gone off i would
have cleared the box right and hit the
concrete from 40 feet so i wouldn't be
here now
so they saved me in a way but and ever
since that day
for myself performing any type of high
fall or anything from height falling
into a rig
i will build the rig as big as you
possibly can so i was lucky that day
nothing beats the adrenaline buzz of
actually being
the performer performing a great
principal stunt
if i stand up in any position and i
hesitate in any way shape or form
it's time to step back hang up my pads
and let someone else do it
i'm now 50 feet 40 feet
30 feet 20 feet all the time looking
checking looking
and at 20 feet i got onto the left hand
wing clambering over that door lip
and then i stood onto the wing and was
able to stand on the wing momentarily